[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a filipino thriller
romance film called the girl allergic to
wifi
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
aries and maca are high schoolers who
have been best friends since
kindergarten
one morning aries notices a beautiful
girl outside the school and is instantly
attracted to her as makka makes fun of
him for it the new girl approaches them
asking for directions to the principal's
office ares forgets how to talk for a
few seconds before pulling himself
together and helping her with the
directions for the next few weeks he
spends hours thinking about the girl
through people in the school he finds
out that the girl's name is norma one
day aries is on the basketball court
helping his popular brother with
something norma arrives with a friend
and reveals that she is actually dating
his brother leo ares is heartbroken by
the revelation but hides it behind an
expressionless face
during dinner he asks leo if it is true
leo affirms that she was only a rebound
from his last relationship at first but
he has recently started to like her ares
doesn't tell him how he feels about
norma scared of ruining their
relationship
every day he watches them together and
drowns in misery he tries to move on but
the fact that they are the most
instagrammable couple doesn't help he is
forced to watch them together in all of
norma's posts
one weekend the students are preparing
for a school program when ares gets a
call from leo he is having some
relationship problems with norma and
wants aries to give her the phone
suddenly norma's nose starts bleeding
aries and her best friend margot help
her to the bathroom just when they think
she's fine she falls unconscious
she is immediately rushed to the
hospital to run a cat scan the doctor
reviews the test but sees nothing out of
the ordinary norma insists he must be
missing something because she's been
getting strange rashes on her back leo
and aries come to visit her at the
hospital norma thinks that the school's
bathroom has healing powers because it's
the only place where she doesn't feel
dizzy the others believe it's only a
coincidence but aries starts researching
about the phenomenon after spending a
few hours on the internet he comes
across a condition called
electromagnetic hypersensitivity
this means that norma is allergic to the
electromagnetic waves emitted by phones
and other devices
she feels better in the bathroom because
it is a dead zone where the phones do
not pick up any signal when norma's
mother is told about this she mentions
that her bedroom is also a dead spot
hence norma can only fall asleep in her
bed the doctor discloses that there is
no definitive way to prove that she is
suffering from the syndrome but even if
she does the cure to it has not yet been
found the family tries various
alternative methods from acupuncture to
hypnotism but nothing works
leo is so concerned about his girlfriend
that he performs very poorly in an
important basketball match he is tired
of having to run around norma but feels
guilty when he chooses basketball over
her
her condition keeps on getting worse
with each therapy session and by the end
of two weeks she can hardly walk the
family decides to send her to her
grandparents home which is in the
countryside and has no wi-fi or
electronic devices she is bound to get
better if she lives in the area norma is
glad that she gets to spend time with
her family however she is afraid that
she and leo cannot handle a
long-distance relationship
using her absence her so-called best
friend margot spreads rumors about her
being pregnant
matcha gets a hint of it and tells aries
leo promised to visit norma every
weekend however he gets lost on the way
and has to return home
meanwhile aries and matcha drive with
norma's mother so they do not have any
difficulty it turns out that leo
prioritized basketball practice instead
of accompanying them in the morning
norma is disheartened because she hasn't
talked to him for a whole week because
there is no wi-fi the next weekend is
also the same she excitedly waits for
her boyfriend who never arrives while
aries and matcha visit her with several
gifts
aries has also made a tinfoil hat that
is supposed to deflect the
electromagnetic waves and help her norma
is thankful that he's doing so much for
her recovery but she secretly wishes leo
was the one doing it
during their next visit matcha shows
norma a screenshot of margot making fun
of her the group decides to teach her a
lesson although aries is skeptical about
the plan they make aries dress up as
margot and take pictures of him then
matcha hacks a group chat and posts a
picture of margot and norma together
saying that margot forced norma to have
an abortion the news makes norma's
friend stop talking to her however the
plan backfires when the screenshot of
the message goes around the school and
people start believing that norma
actually had an abortion the next
weekend leo visits norma for the first
time in weeks she excitedly runs to him
but he pushes her back
his teammates and coach also saw the
abortion post and think that he forced
norma to do it he is furious at her
because the rumor might cost him his
entire basketball career norma
apologizes but leo is in no mood to
listen
he breaks up with her before driving
back to the city norma is heartbroken
after the incident she hardly sleeps or
eats which slows her recovery after a
little encouragement from her
grandmother she writes a letter to leo
apologizing and asking for a visit leo
gets the letter but asks the maid to
throw it away without even reading it
aries feels bad for norma hence he
writes a reply on his brother's behalf
soon they begin exchanging letters
almost every day the letters make norma
fall in love with leo even more unaware
that aries is the one writing them she
wakes up every day waiting for a reply
and is seemingly happier than she had
been for the past month
one day matcha aries and norma go
cycling around the neighborhood they
come across some children playing with a
string phone the group gives it a try
but the device doesn't work
knowing that norma cannot hear him aries
tells her that he loves her through the
phone
following that they go to the bridge
that is the border of the village
further away from the bridge is a cliff
that norma wants to visit but cannot
because of her condition aries urges her
to try to see if the tin foil really
works for a few seconds she feels normal
but then her nose starts to bleed again
they quickly return home and help her
aries feels responsible because he urged
her to go past the bridge but norma
assures him that she is fine the
following week is norma's birthday her
grandmother invites all of them to the
party but all normal wants is for leo to
be there in the following scene matcha
and aries are at the grocery store
matcha knows that he has been writing
the letters and wants him to tell norma
the truth aries also knows it is the
right thing to do but he cannot bring
himself to hurt her on the day of her
birthday norma is eagerly waiting for
leo aries makes up an excuse that he
will be late but norma is willing to
wait as long as she can as a birthday
present aries made her a car covered
with aluminum foil to take her to the
cliff she wanted to visit he has done
more research on electromagnetic
deflection and thinks that the car would
work better than the hat the three give
it a try and are ecstatic when it
actually works they drive to the cliff
and watch the sunset together as they
talk about different things norma
reveals that she wanted to be a pilot
before getting sick but has given up on
the dream
on their way back home matcha leaves
them alone for a while so aries can tell
norma the truth although nervous he does
the right thing and tells her the
letters were from him not from leo
norma is shocked and doesn't know what
to think of it she was under the
impression that her relationship with
leo was back on track but knowing that
he is still mad at her breaks her heart
again they drive back home in silence
but are met with another surprise when
they see leo waiting for her at the door
he apologizes for everything and the two
reconcile still norma cannot get the
thought of aries out of her head
starting that day she and leo go back to
their normal selves but whenever they
spend time together leo is either sleepy
or tired because of basketball practice
norma understands his problem but
realizes that she liked him in the
letters way more than she does in real
life one day at school aries is
approached by a girl who asks him to
tell leo to pick up her calls confused
ary inquires who she is when the girl
discloses that she is leo's girlfriend
later that day he confronts leo about
her and he admits that he dated her
right after breaking up with norma he
tries to rationalize it by claiming that
he loves nora and was sad after the
breakup but aries is not convinced the
next day the brothers visit her again
aries urges leo to tell her the truth
but he is too much of a coward to admit
his mistake the three go on a walk
together when a blue and yellow
butterfly lands on aries shoulder leo
and norma bring out their cameras to
take a picture when norma suddenly
notices a picture of leo and a girl in
his preview window leo quickly puts his
phone inside his pocket and pretends
like he doesn't know what norma is
talking about norma furiously walks back
to the house while leo follows her
claiming that the girl is just a friend
she asks aries to tell her the truth and
that puts him in a dilemma he takes his
brother's side and affirms that the girl
is just his friend
however norma doesn't believe him she
belittles the two for making a fool out
of her and asks them both to go away
back at home aries and leo get into an
argument ares wants his brother to admit
his mistake and respect norma but leo
retaliates that ares is no saint himself
it turns out that he knows about aries
true feelings for norma before the two
get into a physical fight aerys walks
away and drives back to norma's home she
refuses to talk to him but he waits for
her for an entire day when she still
doesn't come out of her room he leaves
her a message in her grandmother's old
recorder on the drive back home aries
mother asked him to pick up leo from a
bar where he is drinking with his
friends although they are not on good
terms ares goes to help him leo
apologizes and hugs his brother knowing
that he was in the wrong after
reconciling they drive back home
leo admits that he is not good enough
for a girl like norma and gives aries
the green light to tell her how he feels
just when aries starts believing he and
norma might have a happy ending their
car is hit by a truck the next morning
nora is informed that the accident
injured leo severely but it killed aries
her heart plummets at the news and she
breaks down crying she is persistent
about going to his funeral even if it
makes her sick her grandmother gives her
the tape recorder before she leaves for
the funeral their car stops working when
they reach the bridge while everyone is
busy norma takes the opportunity to
listen to the recording on it aries has
expressed his love for the first time he
tells her about how he fell in love with
her when he first saw her but never
confessed because she was happy with his
brother as tears run down her face
a blue and yellow butterfly appears on
the window it looks exactly like the one
that had sat on aries shoulder the
previous day she follows it outside and
it leads her to the other side of the
bridge even without the aluminum foil
norma feels fine she realizes that aries
is by her side at that moment the family
then goes to the funeral where leo is in
a wheelchair cut to a few years later we
see norma get into an airplane as its
pilot
she keeps aries picture in front of her
and asks him if he is ready to fly the
movie ends as she takes off into the air
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching